un portrait pour terminer celui d'une
référence dans le monde de la
marionnette
son nom ne vous dit peut être rien
pourtant mehdi garrigues et notamment le
papa de jean marc le petit singe
malpolis jeff pana clock
c'est à tour que le trentenaire a créé
sur mesure des marionnettes pour la
scène où la télévision rencontre avec un
passionné du bébé de chaud ou des mini
key c'est à l'été météo grâce à la
bienvenue dans l'atelier de mehdi
garrigue
ce tourangeau de 34 ans et
marionnettiste et passionné depuis son
plus jeune âge
moi j'ai été baigné dans les muppets les
guignols je me suis pris de passion pour
ces personnages qui sont à la fois des
personnages de deux imaginaires mais en
même temps ils sont dans le réal et son
encre et il n'existe pas comme le dessin
animé et du coup ça devait verser temps
je me suis mis à faire ma première
marionnette pour en avoir une à moi
depuis mes 10 compte plusieurs centaines
de marionnettes à son actif souvent
réalisés dans un style me pète
ses oeuvres sont principalement
destinées à des émissions de télévision
des pièces de théâtre ou encore des
publicités ce qu'il oblige souvent à se
creuser la tête
il faut avoir l'aspiration des fois on
est là on cherche on cherche on tâtonne
on a plein de contraintes à prendre en
compte les contraintes esthétiques faut
que ce soit joli il faut que ça réponde
à la demande du client
en même temps il faut que ça à répondre
aux contraintes de manipulation faut
qu'une manette ce soit léger agréable
que ça bouge bien qu'on donne une vision
de la vie à travers ce personnage
parmi ses réalisations les plus célèbres
on compte la marionnette de capucine
vainqueur de la france a un incroyable
talent en 2019 ou encore michel co
animateur d'une émission avec jamel
debbouze mais sa création la plus
célèbre est sans doute jean-marc le
singe orange du ventriloque jeff pana
clock m'a dit que cherchait quelqu'un
pour lui faire sa marionnette la plus
faire son propre jean-marc la nuit et du
coup ben voilà on a fait une poignée de
main et puis et puis voilà il est venu
chez moi et faire des essais et c'est ce
statut de papa de jean marc permet à
mehdi de connaître les moindres détails
de la vie du personnage quitte à en
révéler quelques secrets parfaite
jean-marc il passe par machine je me
perds tu es là
aux yeux du monde il n'y a qu'un jean
marc à mes yeux il y en a eu plusieurs
voilà avec la crise sanitaire l'activité
de mehdi garrigue a un peu baissé mais
ce gepetto des temps modernes a tout de
même de nombreux projets en cours
il travaille notamment sur l'adaptation
des mystérieuses cités d'or en comédie
musicale